>>> CBS SAYS THAT LONGTIME
TELEVISION HOST SHARON OSBOURNE
HAS DECIDED TO LEAVE "THE TALK."
IT FOLLOWS A CONTROVERSIAL
EXCHANGE WITH HER CO-HOST ON
AIR.
OSBOURNE DEFENDED PIERS MORGAN'S
CRITICISM OF MEGHAN AND PRINCE
HARRY AND OTHERS ACCUSE HER OF
MAKING RACIST AND HOMOPHOBIC
COMMENTS.
VLAD WITH MORE.
>> GOOD MORNING AGAIN, FOLKS.
"THE TALK" HAS BEEN ON HIATUS
FOR TWO WEEKS FOLLOWING A HEATED
DISCUSSION ON MARCH 10th BETWEEN
SHARON OSBOURNE AND SHERYL
UNDERWOOD.
DURING A DISCUSSION OF PRINCE
HARRY AND MEGHAN MARKLE,
OSBOURNE CAME TO THE DEFENSE OF
PIERS MORGAN.
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF MAKING
RACIST STATEMENTS AGAINST MARKLE
AND SAID HE DIDN'T BELIEVE
ANYTHING SHE SAID DURING THE
SIT-DOWN WITH OPRAH.
OSBOURNE WAS ASKED ABOUT
STANDING BY A PERSON ACCUSED OF
RACISM AND SAID SHE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY MORGAN'S COMMENTS
WERE RACIST AND TOLD UNDERWOOD,
"DON'T TRY TO CRY.
IF ANYONE SHOULD BE TRYING IT
SHOULD BE ME."
AFTER IT AIRED SHE APOLOGIZED TO
"ANYONE OF COLOR I OFFENDED OR
TO ANYONE THAT FEELS CONFUSED OR
LET DOWN BY WHAT I SAID."
FORMER CO-HOST HOLLY ROBINSON
PETE AND LEAH REMINI HAVE
ACCUSED HER OF RACIST AND
HOMOPHOBIC BEHAVIOR.
SHE DENIES THE ALLEGATIONS.
AFTER AN INVESTIGATION, IT WAS
REVEALED THAT OSBOURNE WOULD NOT
BE RETURNING TO "THE TALK" AND
SAID, "ADS PART OF OUR REVIEW WE
CONCLUDED THAT SHARON'S BEHAVIOR
TOWARD HER CO-HOST DURING THE
MARCH 10 EPISODE DID NOT ALIGN
FOR W OUR VALUES FOR A
RESPECTFUL WORKPLACE."
THEY SAID THEY HAVE BEEN
COORDINATING WORKSHOPS,
LISTENING SESSIONS, AND TRAINING
ABOUT EQUITY, INCLUSION, AND
CULTURAL AWARENESS FOR THE
HOSTS, PRODUCERS, AND CREW.
CBS NEWS HAS REACHED OUT TO
OSBOURNE FOR A COMMENT.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
NO REPLACEMENT HAS BEEN
ANNOUNCED YET.
"THE TALK" WILL RESUME AIRING
ORIGINAL EPISODES ON MONDAY,
APRIL 12th.
>> IT'S SUCH AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION.
I SAW AN INTERVIEW THAT SHARON
DID WITH KEVIN FRIESAZIER.
SHE FELT BLIND SIDED.
WHEN SHE SAID TO SHERYL YOU
SHOULDN'T CRY, I SHOULD BE THE
ONE CRYING, SHE SAID SHE WAS
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION DURING
THE COMMERCIAL BREAK AND DIDN'T
GET IT.
IT TURNED -- ONE THING LED TO
ANOTHER LED TO ANOTHER.
LEAH AND HOLLY CAME OUT WITH
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING WAS THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH HER.
THE WHOLE THING HAS BEEN
UNFORTUNATE FROM BEGINNING TO
END.
HOW DO WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH PEOPLE AND DISAGREE --
>> YEAH --
>> AND --
>> I SUSPECT THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT CAME OUT
AFTERWARDS FROM HOLLY ROBINSON
PEETE AND LEAH REMINI ABOUT THE
THINGS SHE'S ALLEGED TO HAVE
SAID --
>> THEY'RE STANDING FIRMLY
BEHIND THE COMMENTS, TOO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> SHARON HAS ACKNOWLEDGED SHE
WAS HAVING A GO AT A FRIEND, AS
SHE PUD IT, SHERYL UNDERWOOD.
IT'S THE SURROUNDING THINGS THAT
MAKE IT HARD TO COME BACK FROM.
>> IF